chicken stir fry with rice noodles some
of the best street food I've ever eaten
was in Asia every one of those little
markets was filled with smells of
delicious food that all centered around
an Asian staple noodles learn to cook
those properly and you'll be surprised
how quick and easy it is to knock off a
delicious dinner
first off we're going to soak our
noodles
now these are rice noodles into a bowl
and just pour the hot water over the
rice noodles soak
and rehydrate
12 to 15 minutes to soften up if you've
got to Wok perfect if not just a normal
sized frying pan with big sloping sides
pan on
get it really nice and hot
chicken breast very lean hardly any fat
on there you've got this little fillet
just slice that off
now the secret to getting it really nice
and thin and to cut it into strips take
your knife
keep it nice and flat on the board and
sort of slice it in half like a sort of
scallop
like that we call this butterfly in the
chicken take a rolling pin
and nice and gently roll over the
chicken and what it does it sort of
flattens it allows you to slice it even
thinner
and the thinner the slices of the
chicken the sort of crisper it gets the
quicker it Cooks slice it in half
start slicing
these nice
thin slices and the good news is one
chicken breast can serve two or three
easily
next wash your knife and finely slice
garlic
a thinner the garlic
crispier
this is a young
tender broccoli just slice them down
I want a bite to the broccoli
and normally you sort of paste the dish
with one-third noodles one-third
vegetables and one third of your protein
chicken
with a dish that takes literally minutes
to put together it's really important to
get everything organized everything
needs to be at your fingertips
touch
of olive oil get a pan really nice and
ready
just starting to smoke drop the chicken
in first
just salt pepper
open up those little strands of chicken
nice
[Music]
once you've started to sear off the
chicken get the garlic in
now let that get really nice and crispy
the way to do it is to sort of spread
all the chicken the garlic up the side
of the pan
to see why it's so important to cut the
chicken thin strips because it colors
and Cooks at the same time as well
really really crucial
now that Garlic's getting really nice
and crispy broccoli in
feel strange putting raw broccoli in
like that normally we'll blanch it in
boiling water dry it out but you want
that crunch now soy sauce that helps to
season it but also stains beautifully
soy sauce in
foreign
a little wipe out
a little teaspoon of olive oil get that
what really nicely oiled again
drain your noodles
they're beautiful
this is a really exciting way of
finishing this quick stir fry very
classic two eggs in
foreign
give that a really good whisk
[Music]
sort of almost
spread it at the side of the pan
like you season the eggs noodles
in
chicken and broccoli in
[Music]
and give that
a really nice mix
we want the egg to sort of almost bring
the dish together
the eggs cooked
make sure you got that nice even
distribution of
chicken broccoli garlic
lovely
I'm gonna just finish that fresh lime
and there you have a very simple
delicious stir-fry with rice noodles
foreign
food staple and they come in all shapes
and sizes they're so easy to cook
healthy but really delicious here are
three effortless recipes that are ready
literally in minutes
first up noodle soup with poached egg
and spring onions
[Music]
add miso paste the boiling water
Japanese misum has a wonderful deep
Savory richness and is brilliant in
soups
great in fresh ginger
dry shiitake mushrooms that have been
soaked in water
season with soy sauce
crack an egg add it to the broth and
poach for two to three minutes
and thinly sliced portobello mushrooms
to a serving Bowl
put in fresh medium egg noodles which
will heat through in the hot miso broth
add spinach
[Music]
then simply spoon the broth into your
bowl
top with the egg
fresh chopped spring onions
simple so good and so delicious ready in
10 minutes super fast noodle soup with
poached egg and spring onions
my next easy dish using the versatile
noodle is stir-fried pork noodles
first marinade pork mince and shaoxing
rice wine a fortified Chinese wine
soy sauce and sesame oil
next fry chopped ginger in hot olive oil
and garlic
[Music]
next add Szechuan peppercorns which have
a wonderful lemony flavor and gives a
pleasant tingling sensation
now add your marinated pork mince
and brown
if you want more seasoning add extra soy
sauce
then add fiery chili bean paste
and rice wine vinegar
[Music]
adding cooked egg noodles
mixed together
finally top with chopped spring onion
and toasted sesame seeds
[Music]
packed with flavor and on the table in
15 minutes delicious stir-fried pork
noodles
[Music]
my next noodle dish you can knock up in
no time is noodles with chili ginger and
lemongrass
[Music]
add chopped onions to hot olive oil
garlic
chili
and Fry
grating Ginger
next lemongrass first Basher with a
knife doing this will help release its
wonderful lemony flavor and scent now
aromatic kaffir lime leaves then ground
cumin coriander and turmeric
next add cream coconut
chicken stock fish sauce
and simmer
so rice vermicelli noodles in hot water
[Applause]
[Music]
drain
and add to your serving Bowl
pour over the aromatic soup broth
finish with coriander
and chopped chili
on the table in around 20 minutes
noodles with chili ginger and lemongrass
real fast food
fast healthy delicious free mouthwashing
recipes guaranteed to help you master
the art of incredible tasting noodles